اهلا بكم من جديد احدث قرار اليابان
الاخير بمضاعفه ميزانيتها الدفاعيه مع
التركيز على تنميه القدرات الهجوميه احدث
صدمه لدى عده دول في اسيا خاصه ان هذا
الامر يشكل انتهاء سياسه انتاجتها اليابان
منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بامتلاك اسلحه دفاعيه فقط
العديد من الخبراء يعتقدون ان السبب وراء
الخطوه اليابانيه هو تعاضم القدرات
الصينيه العسكريه وعلى الجانب الاخر تنامي
القدرات الصاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه للحديث
اكثر عن تداعيات القرار الياباني وكذلك
التحركات العسكريه الصينيه الاخيره معنا
الباحث في شؤون الدفاع في المركز الدولي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه من لندن السيد
اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريا لماذا اليابان
الان تتبنى ميزانيه عسكريه بهذا الحجم ذات
الطبيعه النوعيه في شكل الاسلحه لاول مره
منذ اكثر من نصف القطر
للتطورات الاقليميه والمتطلبات الامنيه
المتزايده الصين تحولت من مصدر
وخلال سنوات العشر الماضيه استمرت كوريا
الشماليه بكونها مشكله وكذلك روسيا اما
الاسلحه سواء كانت دفاعيه او هجوميه
فالامر يخص النوايا اكثر مما يخص القدرات
فاصواريخ الكروز بعيده المدى على سبيل
المثال يمكن ان تعدى اسلحه دفاعيه في اطار
الردع التقليدي وجديد بالذكر ان اليابان
بدات تكمل علاقتها الدفاعيه الواطيده
بالولايات المتحده عبر علاقات متناميه مع
بريطانيا
ومشاركتها في برنامج المستقبل للطائرات
القتاليه مع لندن وروما
ليس خفيا بانه هناك سباق تسلح منذ فتره في
القاره الاسيويه لكن بعد خطوه اليابان هل
تعتقد بانه حده هذا السباق ستزداد بعد
القرار الياباني الاخير
اعتقده
لسباق التسلح في المنطقه وعلى الرغم من ان
هذا المصطلح يولد التوترات دون ايجاد
الحلول لكن تحصين اليابان لقدرتها واعاده
رسمتها قد يولد ردت فعل صينيه على سبيل
المثال بخلاف ان ما تقوم به طوكيو هو ردته
فعل للتحديث الصين لجيشها وتعزيز موقفها
العدوانيه اضافه الى التطورات الحاصله في
كوريا الشماليه وروسيا مصر دوغلاس على مدى
سنوات قدمت الصين نفسها كوه اقتصاديه الان
يبدو ان لديها برامج تسحيه تختلف عن
البرامج السابقه اللي بكين برايك ما هي
اولويات التسلح الان التي يعني تريد بكين
ان تتمتع بها في المستقبل
مره في المجالات الجويه والفضائيه
والبحريه وفي النطاق الجوي وهو مجال
الاقتصادي من خلال العقود قليله المنصارمه
انتقلت الصين من موقفها كقوه محدوده جدا
الى قوه جويه ذات قدرته عاليه جدا
وتحولت من اعتمادها على التصاميم الروسيه
الى الانتاج المحلي ولديها القاعده
الصناعيه التكميليه لدعم كل ذلك مثال على
ذلك هو القوات الجويه الصينيه التي لديها
الان مئه وخمسون طائره من نوع شندول جي 20
القتاليه المتطوره جدا اما روسيا
بالمقارنه فقد انتجت 10 فقط من طائرات
سوخوي 57 المكافئه اما فيما يخص القدره
النوويه فان بكين على ما يبدو تبتعد عن
موقف للرضع الادنى بهدف الوصول الى مستوى
الولايات المتحده مع مرور الوقت والبحريه
الصينيه قدمت صاروخا ماليزيا يطلق من
الغواصات والقوات الجويه تؤدي دور النوويه
كما تطور الصين ثلاثه من الصين لاطلاق
الصواريخ العابره للقارات
فيما يتعلق بتيوان
يعني كثيرا ما حذرت الصين من احتماليه
استقلال تايوان
اعتقد رايك بانه الصين على مقربه من اتخاذ
خطوات عسكريه لضمه تايوان مثلا
قائما اما مدى احتماليه حدوث ذلك فيعتمد
على اسلوب تفكيرنا متفائل ام متشائم
هناك الكثير من التحالفات في منطقه بحر
الصين الجنوبي وكذلك في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ لكن برايك هذه التحالفات التي
تقودها بشكل او باخر الولايات المتحده هي
كافيه لرضع بكين عن اي نوايا سواء فيما
يتعلق بتيوان او فيما يتعلق باي دوله اخرى
من حلفاء الولايات المتحده
وكذلك لاعب دوري الردعي في وجه الصين ان
تكون مؤثره مؤخرا مستر مستر بعض الدول
التي كانت تعتمد على الولايات المتحده مثل
كوريا الجنوبيه وكذلك اليابان
يبدو وكانها تريد ان يكون لديها صناعه
دفاعيه خاصه بها هل هذا القرار نابع من
تخوف من اعتمادهم على الولايات المتحده ام
ان يريدون ان يقيموا شراك دفاعيه مع
الولايات المتحده شراكه منبطه ليس فقط
تعتمد على الولايات المتحده وعلى قرار
البيت الابيض بشكل اخر
اعتقد انه من الطبيعي للدول ان تطور
قدرتها العسكريه وقواعدها الصناعيه
الدفاعيه وتسعى لزياده قدره الانتاج
الوطني في نفس الوقت الذي تبقى فيه
الولايات المتحده شريكا اقليميا مهما كما
ترون فعلى الرغم من ان اليابان توصل
علاقتها بريطانيا وايطاليا عبر برنامج
طائرات قتاليه فهي لم تقطع علاقاتها مع
اميركا فعلاقتها مع بريطانيا وايطاليا
مكمله لعلاقتها المستمره مع امريكا
باري الباحث في شؤون الدفاع في المركز
الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا
كنت معنا من لندن